in 2015 the migrant crisis in europe
brought
unprecedented social strife and the
meteoric rise of the far right
all across the continent the crisis
itself had two main theaters
the mediterranean sea and the balkan
peninsula and the vast majority of
migrants came through the balkans
shown by this frontex chart thus making
their way to western european countries
such as germany or sweden
enter viktor orban the far-right white
nationalist prime minister of hungary
directly standing between the balkans
and western europe
now in far-right circles and in
hungarian government propaganda
it's a popular talking point that
hungary and orban in general protected
europe from the migrants in 2015
thus helping to keep europe white and or
to
foil the jewish cabal's plans depending
on how far gone you are
and here we have a tweet from zoltan
kovacs the hungarian government
spokesman echoing this very sentiment
no pm orban did not let illegal
immigrants into europe
in fact hungary was one of the few eu
member states that stood up against
illegal migration
but was it now unfortunately for zoltan
kovac
in 2015 i was living in hungary and
commuting daily on the very route the
migrants were taking to western europe
and being interested in the crisis
i was also reading all the articles i
could get my hands on regarding the
migrant crisis
and the events inside the country so
based on my first hand knowledge of
events i can confidently say that the
hungarian spokesman is lying to you
right now
and so my claim is that the hungarian
government has deliberately and actively
exacerbated the problem
they made the crisis much worse on
purpose
alright so this is a rather bold claim i
fully realized that and as we know
extraordinary claims do require
extraordinary evidence
so what we're going to do here is we are
going to go through the events
chronologically and see whether my
claims hold any water
so our story begins on the 2nd of
february 2015
in the morning at the train station of
djir a city in northwest hungary not far
from the austrian border
now at this point the migrant crisis has
been going on for more than a year
with the number of asylum claims in the
european union increasing by 44
and in southern europe by 95 percent and
these numbers are according to the unhcr
asylum trends 2014 statistics
right so why did i choose the 2nd of
february 2015 as my starting point
well stay tuned people on that day at
the eur train station about 200
kossovian migrants were removed from the
real jet heading towards
germany and eventually taken away to
asylum custody
now as a side note kosovians themselves
are european
kosovo is a european country it's in the
middle of the balkans
and kosovians themselves are considered
white so what's the problem here
well you see kosovo also happens to be
95.6
muslim according to 2011 stats anyway
from encyclopedia britannica
so for warband's perspective it actually
makes perfect sense that he held them up
or did he you see the local publication
that reported on the events
also went around and interviewed some
locals about the situation
and they had some rather interesting
things to say
and so they're right one passenger
waiting at the station noted to our
colleague with a sour smile
that on yesterday's three o'clock rail
jet from budapest kelletti there were
even more foreigners
none of whom were checked however
according to him there were so many of
them on the train that there was barely
any space left to stand
so what on earth has gotten into the
hungarian authorities
because as far as i know this was the
first major action taken against
migrants where they actually stopped
them from traveling to western europe
well you see on the 2nd of february
2015 german chancellor angela merkel was
visiting hungary
right but see at this point in the first
half of 2015
fides victor orban's party had a
relevant problem
namely that they were dropping in polls
pretty severely losing about 13 percent
due to corruption scandals inefficient
governance etc
so they started using the migrant crisis
as a political tool to regain supporters
and this approach makes sense really you
know being at the forefront of solving
this big crisis that's hitting the
country
and so they started rolling out the
first measures to counteract the migrant
crisis
four months later on the 6th of june
2015
which was a billboard campaign and so
they plastered three kinds of billboards
all over the country
from budapest the capital all the way to
the smallest of villages
these were if you come to hungary you
cannot take hungarian's jobs
if you come to hungary you have to
respect our culture
and the third one if you come to hungary
you have to respect our laws
but quick thinking viewers might notice
a problem with these billboards
namely that they are written in
hungarian you know if you want to
communicate something to
mostly middle eastern migrants it would
make sense to write these billboards in
arabic or at least in english but of
course these billboards were not
intended for the migrants themselves
despite being aimed at them these
billboards were a giant virtue signal to
fidesz's old
mostly rural conservative supporters and
keep in mind that as this is going on
people are marching through the country
non-stop from turkey
across the balkans through hungary to
western europe
and although there are some attempts to
hold them up or hinder them
this is only enough to have a bunch of
people collect
around the kelletti railway station the
station from which the
international trains go to western
europe and just hang out there
waiting for a chance to escape hungary
and then came the idea for which i find
orban is praised the most
in far-right circles the wall or rather
a
wire fence and as the hungarian
government proudly announced
on the 29th of august 2015 the fence was
finally done on the serbian border
here it is on the map marked with red
now do we see the problem here but as
the government was proudly presenting
the professional and very effective
chicken fence including a freight car
from mad max
the proverbial dark clouds gathered over
budapest
you see the authorities were instructed
to pull all migrants off trains no
exceptions
you know this is the thing that they
said they did from the beginning but
only started now
which in practice meant that if you got
into the country through the wireframes
which was not
difficult you actually had trouble
moving on from hungary
see once you were in the country you
could get on a train to western europe
if you had a valid ticket but then if
you met a police patrol on the train
they pulled you off if you had no
passport
and so basic arithmetics what happens if
the number of incoming people is higher
than the number of outgoing people
they start building up and that's
exactly what happened turning the
underpass system around kennedy into a
makeshift refugee camp over the course
of a few months
by the end of august 2015. so instead of
a couple hundred people
now you had multiple thousands all
hanging around the railway station
wanting to get on a train
and you know from the migrants
perspective if you've paid thousands of
euros to smugglers to get you through
the sea
from turkey to greece and then you go
through the balkans and make it to
hungary
you'll be damned to give up and turn
back if the only thing separating you
from western europe is a two-hour train
ride
and so the crowd is building up around
kelleti and people are getting more and
more impatient
you know having to hang out in an
underpass with your family in a tent
surrounded by a bunch of strangers
potentially for months on end while also
being
so damn close to your destination
doesn't exactly inspire you to be
patient and understanding
so at this point the writing was on the
wall something was going to happen
eventually
the tensions were building without any
sort of outlet for them and what did the
hungarian government
do nothing they watched as the crowd
grew around the station day by day
and did absolutely nothing about it the
basic amenities such as showers toilets
chargers etc were either provided by the
city authorities which
are separate from the government or by
non-governmental organizations
so this is where we are right now some
people actually do manage to get to
western europe with valid tickets but
others are not so lucky and stumble into
a police patrol
that sends them back to kelletti and
then on the 30th of august 2015
the police decided to close down
kelletti meaning that now
even if you had a valid ticket you
couldn't get to the train unless you
also had valid travel documents
and it only took more than a year for
the authorities to reach this point
but this closure made a lot of migrants
pretty pissed you know international
train tickets are not cheap
especially if you have to buy them for
your whole family you can easily be
looking at one or two hundred dollars
per family which is a pretty substantial
amount for refugees and you cannot get
your money back because the ticket
office is also inside the station and
you are not allowed there so your money
goes to waste
and so the tensions get even higher but
there is no open conflict yet
because one day later on the 31st of
august kennedy opened again
and so hundreds of migrants managed to
crowd onto the trains and leave hungary
and these migrants actually all reached
western europe as far as i know so
naturally words spread around migrants
like wildfire that the authorities are
now letting you go to western europe if
you have a ticket
no police patrols on the trains no
police at the station
if you have a ticket you can go and so
even more people started crowding around
the station
you know all those stragglers who might
be out in the city somewhere basically
all of them were now in front of
kelletti
waiting to leave hungary until the next
day on the 1st of september 2015 without
any prior warning
police have again looked down kelletti
causing even more people to lose money
on their tickets
and according to reports the hungarian
railways was actually selling
tickets even the night before and then
two days later
on the 3rd of september 2015 the line of
police have once again disappeared
without any prior warning
and so seeing that the migrants started
running towards the station like insane
since you know now is your chance you
have no idea when the police will be
back
but you do want to get out of the
country before they return so thousands
of people stream into the station
causing the hungarian railway to panic
and completely block all traffic towards
western hungary and western europe
so we got thousands of frustrated
migrants milling around the station
without any information or guidance just
waiting for a train to come
but traffic is shut down so trains are
not coming
except for one train which was sent to
kelitti by accident
from western hungary while the tracks
were supposed to be closed you know
that's the organizational skills of the
hungarian railways for you
and the train was drawn
by this locomotive with the graphics on
its side depicting people running from
hungary to germany through barbed wire
breaking through walls
the illustration itself commemorates the
pan-european picnic of 1989 when hungary
led through a bunch of east germans to
west germany
basically as refugees can you see a
potential problem with this illustration
given the situation at kelletti
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
ah
so migrants crowded onto the train and
at this point they just wouldn't get off
you know understandably so after all
this back and forth and so this goes on
for multiple hours the train is not
going anywhere and the railways keep
announcing on the pa system that there
will be no trains towards western europe
and then they start the train towards
western europe and they run it all the
way from budapest to bichke
which is about one fourth of the way
towards vienna and then they announce
that the train is not going to western
europe and then police show up and try
to pull people off the train
and i must commend the migrants here for
showing such civility and restraint here
you know white europeans would be
smashing [ __ ] up at this point
you know if these people were british
tourists they would already be fist
fighting the police or something
so of course news of people getting
pulled off at bc made it back to
kelletti and they started protesting
not smashing things up not setting
things on fire but
protesting and at this point every
reasonable person should have been in
support of them
you know first they're told they can go
and then they cannot and then they can
and then they cannot and then they buy
two tickets both of them get invalidated
and they don't get their money back
and then one train comes in and then
they say it doesn't go and then it goes
and then it doesn't go after all and
then police show up i mean
[ __ ] off you know so the police tried to
fix the situation
and tell people that hey if they get to
bitsky if they go to the refugee camp
there
and stay there they can get food and the
migrants are like
no [ __ ] you we just want to leave this
country but by the end of the day the
police kicked the migrants out of the
station
and everything was back the way it was
before as in hundreds of people camping
around the square and no one allowed
inside the station without travel
documents
and if you thought the situation could
not get any more absurd
well you just wait you see the migrants
at this point were pretty [ __ ] pissed
and they've also realized what
hungarians learn at a very young age
the hungarian government is not to be
trusted so after some collective
organizing they've decided [ __ ] it we're
just gonna walk to austria
that's right hundreds of people decided
they're gonna walk from budapest to
austria
you know the authorities keep lying to
them nothing is organized they're
running out of food and water
so they all started going with a
one-legged man at the head of the column
from kalati through the grand boulevard
across the elizabeth bridge
through buda and then on the m1 highway
towards vienna
and the m1 highway is also one of the
main transit arteries of the country
and so this is an absolute disaster you
know both financially and pr
wise the situation needs to be
immediately corrected but where is
victor orban well turns out as this
crisis was unfolding he had
other arrangements such as watching the
hungary romania football match
and guess what kind of people also visit
football matches
that's right football hooligans who
aren't exactly famous of their tolerance
of brown people
and so they showed up to kellity where
some of the migrants still remained who
didn't want to go on foot
i started throwing fireworks into the
underpasses you know getting into the
occasional scuffles
thankfully the police were there to
uphold some kind of semblance of water
at least
but at this point the situation was a
general [ __ ]
you know there was a traffic jam on the
m1 highway because of the column
some migrants took to follow the rail
tracks which caused the most congested
rail line in the country to shut down
for security reasons
football holidays were at galati trying
to start [ __ ] and victor orban was still
watching his football match
meanwhile the migrants were progressing
towards vienna and also stopping by the
occasional grocery store to resupply
so this went on until night when the
hungarian government finally made a
decision
around midnight they assembled hundreds
of buses of the budapest transit
authority and whatever other buses they
could find
and simply sent them down the highway to
pick up the migrants and take them to
austria
without any checks or controls mind you
but even this didn't go as well as they
planned
you see the migrants were kind of
suspicious of everything the hungarian
government was doing at this point so
they've put some volunteers on the first
bus and sent it off and then tracked the
boss's position
on gps to see if it's really going where
they promised it would go
and not to a refugee camp and only when
they saw that the bus did indeed arrive
to austria did everyone else get on the
other buses and so they were shipped off
once again without any checking of
travel documents or visas
etc if you were at the side of that road
and you are brown the hungarian
government took you to western europe
for
free oh and by the way as this bus
action was going on
police and budapest were busy battling a
mob of 1 000 football hooligans
who wanted to make their way to kelletti
to i guess beat up some migrants
well i guess the football much ended and
we're throwing [ __ ] at police
and also set a police car on fire yeah i
guess they were passionate about
wanting to protect europe from the
hordes of brown people who want to you
know
destroy the country and burn [ __ ] down
and all that but at this point you know
one might say that the hungarian
government could have been justified in
shipping people to austria
because it was a chaotic situation
completely out of control
so what other choice do they have to
prevent you know rioting and stuff
and that would be a correct assessment
if the busing of migrants didn't
continue
for weeks and weeks afterwards this went
on until mid-october
until the wall huge air quotes was
completely finished
and this is where it was built now do
you see a potential problem with this
arrangement
so yeah all hungary did was divert the
flow of migrants to croatia and slovenia
and the flow of people would actually
not stop until march next year
2016 when all countries on the balkan
peninsula closed down their borders
effectively ending the most severe
period of the eastern european migrant
crisis
in the meantime if you are a brown
person in hungary without any travel
documents
orban gave you a free ride to austria
and the scale really was industrial mind
you
this hungarian state news agency article
described the situation as follows
trains carry migrants continuously from
hyde shalom to austria
shalom being a northwest hungarian
border city
every hour trains full of migrants
arrived to the hedge alone train station
the article says
when a train from kelatti rolls into one
side of the platform
the migrants board the train standing on
the other side under the guidance of
hungarian police
between the arrival and departure of
trains no one can leave the platforms
and it wasn't just the trains from the
south of hungary from uruzke
they basically collected every single
migrant put them on buses
and took them to once again hadeshalom
where they showed them where the border
is
and then just left them there of course
all the migrants went to western europe
and here's some pictures of the empty
refugee camp at sanggoth next to the
austrian border
as you can see it's completely empty
that's because all the migrants at this
point were already in austria
so hundreds of thousands of people made
it to western europe this way
unchecked most of them not even
registered and boy i sure hope that some
unsavory characters will not take
advantage of this regime
you know some people with some religious
fundamentalist ideas who
want to go to western europe and you
know commit some naughty things
and so let's talk about the november
2015 paris attacks
a series of terrorist attacks committed
by isis militants that left 130 people
dead and hundreds more injured
it consisted of three attacks namely the
stad de france stadium suicide bombings
subsequent restaurant shootings and
bombings and of course the bataclan
theater massacre and that alone killed
90 people
and this is salah abdeslam the organizer
of these terrorist attacks
he provided logistics support to the
terrorists and he also recruited them
including in front of kelletti railway
station in budapest where he recruited
two people and then took them to western
europe by car
and those two actually went on and took
part in the paris terrorist attacks
and i want you to take a look at this
picture you know what do we see here
well on the right it's the hungarian
government's latest
billboard at the time which was just a
picture of the migrants walking through
a field and a huge stop sign next to it
and behind it is the hotel where salah
abdeslam actually lived
while he was recruiting at kelleti and
also bought 200
000 sim cards under a homeless person's
name do you know how we know this
after the paris attacks the belgian
secret service noticed that many of the
terrorists have hungarian sim cards
and then the belgians went ahead and
warned the hungarians that you know
maybe they should be investigated or
something and this is how they found out
that it was salah abdeslam
after the terrorist attacks and salah
islam didn't just stop there
in january 2016 he actually came to
hungary to negotiate with the hungarian
far-right militia called nemzetti
artsvanal
led by some gun nut crazy called istvan
jerkers who by the way killed a police
officer when the police tried to raid
his home looking for weapons
and this is just unbelievable it's just
beyond absurd
speaking of which let's read the
hungarian government spokesperson's
tweet again
in light of all this new information no
pm orban did not let illegal immigrants
into europe
in fact hungary was one of the few eu
member states that stood up against
illegal migration
aha in reality it was absolutely in
orban's best interest to have as many
unchecked migrants in western europe as
possible
because if they cause social unrest or
terrorist attacks that will lead to an
increase in far-right support
and the more far-right politicians that
are in power the more political wiggle
room will orban have
who by the way is also a far writer if
you haven't noticed and his political
aspirations
only cost more than 100 people dead and
hundreds more injured
and at the end of it all he gets to
stand up and say that he was the one who
protected europe
thank you for watching please like and
subscribe and let me know what you think
in the comments below